all right so as we have seen in the
previous clip another way that initial
conditions may matter is if a chain has
a periodic structure there are many ways
of defining periodicity some of them are
more mathematical than others let us
consider on one of the most intuitive
ways of doing that so here is the
definition the states in a recurrent
class are periodic if they can be lumped
together or grouped into several
subgroups so that all transitions from
one group lead to the next group so what
does that really mean let us try to
parse out this by looking at a given
example so here we would have a
situation a structure of a diagram in
which D is equals to 2 whenever you are
at a given time in a state in that group
in the next transition you will go to
that group and if you are in that group
at the next transition you will go to
that group so in some sense there is
periodicity and there is somewhat of a
deterministic behavior according to this
transition but there is also some
randomness left we can be in any of
these states within that subgroup but
one thing that is for sure is that
whenever at a given time you are into
one of these states here in that group
if the Markov chain has this specific
structure in the next transition you
will transition to one of these states
here and the next transition after you
will go back here so essentially if your
Markov chain started in one of these
states here at time N equals zero then
at time N equals one it would be here
and then at time N equals two it will be
here times Dement 3 and so and so forth
so every time you would have an even
number then you are guaranteed that the
Markov chain will be in one of these
states here clearly with this kind of
structure it is impossible to have
convergence of the steady state
probabilities this is another example
where you would have a structure of a
diagram in which you have a period of 3
here so in that case here D equals 3 so
here again if you are in one of these
states at a given time then at the next
time the following transition will
guarantee to bring you in that group and
during the next transition you will go
to that group and then again here and
again you will have this kind of
behavior in a very systematic way so if
you started here at time N equals 0 you
would be in that group here at times n
equals 1 and you would be here at N
equals 2 and again N equals 3 here and
equals 4 and equals 5 6 7 8 and you see
the pattern if you look at any time in
the future if the time is of the form 3
times K for any K greater than equal to
0 you are guaranteed that your chain
will be in one of these states otherwise
it will be here or here so here again
you do not have convergence so the
steady states because if you are told
that you started in one of these states
here then you know that whenever you
have a time that is of the form 3 K plus
1 you will be here and so the privateeer
being here will be 0 alright so we have
been able to explain a little bit what a
periodic state is using this definition
now given a Markov chain how can we tell
whether a Markov chain is periodic or
not there are in fact systematic ways of
doing it mathematically but usually
within the types of examples we see in
this class most of them it will be easy
to see we just eyeball the chain and we
tell whether it's parody cannot so let
us see if it is that easy to do
and consider that chain here okay so
let's see is this chain parity cannot I
will give you a couple of seconds to
think about it now I'm gonna help a
little bit I just decide that this one
will be red this one will be red this
one will be red and this one will be red
now I'm asking the same question what do
you think well from the structure it is
clear that this Markov chain is periodic
and as a period of T equals two in some
sense the red state here could be one of
these group these are the red one the
white here will be those here and it is
clear if you look at this diagram that
whenever you are in a red state at the
next transition you are guaranteed to be
in a white state from this one you will
be in white from this one you will be in
a white from this one as well and from
this one as well and whenever you are in
a white state this one this one this one
this one or this one
at the next period you can't it to be in
a red state so this tells you that
sometimes it's not that easy to eyeball
and decide if a Markov chain is periodic
or not if you have for example lots of
lots of states you might have some
trouble doing this exercise on the other
hand something very useful to know
sometimes it's extremely easy to tell
that the chain is not periodic even if
you have a lot of states what is that
case well look at this case here and
suppose for a moment that you have a
soft transition here
well in that case you would have a
transition from a white state to a white
state and you're not guaranteed anymore
that from a white state you would go to
a red state in that sense as soon as you
have a self transition the Markov chain
is a periodic it cannot be periodic so
whenever you have a self transition this
implies that the chain is not periodic
and usually that's the simplest and
easiest way that we can tell most of the
time that the chain is not periodic